uh yeah so hello everyone and welcome to
this lecture this is the second lecture
on introduction to deep learning uh of
the two lectures on this
topic um
so let's just start by recapping what we
covered last lecture so the first
introduction to deep
learning um and my take-home message for
you that I try to impress on you is this
idea that neural networks uh although
they can be incredibly complex
uh can just be simply thought of as
fitting functions to data and this is
just a really useful way of thinking
about training neural
networks um so what do I mean by that we
have some input Vector x uh we pass it
through some neural network function
which depends on some free parameters
and we get out some some output Vector
Y and we just train it by matching the
output of the network to some many many
training examples that we
have and then this noral Network
function just depends on the on the
noral network architecture that you
choose and obviously that function can
be incredibly complex depending on the
the
architecture so for example for MLP the
noral network function is fairly simple
it's just the input Vector Times by this
weight Matrix added with the bias spect
to pass through some activation and
repeated depending on how many layers
you want the MLP to
have and then the other idea that I
tried to impress on you is that uh this
idea of universal approximation and this
this is what makes neural networks so
powerful and why they're applied to so
many different tasks is this property
that you know with enough parameters
they can approximate any arbitrary
arbitary
function and this really allows them to
do you know really impressive tasks like
take an image for example and classify
classify that image that's a really
complicated function to be able to do
that
okay so I also talk about the different
types of tasks that we use deep learning
for uh so I covered supervised learning
so things like regression classification
I also talked about unsupervised
learning so things like feature learning
where you have an image for example and
you want to compress it down into some
Salient low dimensional
representation uh I talked about
generative modeling which is uh trying
to generate a sample so for example
generate an image uh based on lots of
examples of images from that
distribution
and then I also talks about Auto
regression so this is the task of
predicting future values from past past
values but I think what's really
important to still remember is in all
cases you know this is we're always
training a network to fit some data with
some loss function it's just the way
that we arrange that data and label that
data is different depending on the
task
okay and I also talked a little bit more
in detail about how we actually train uh
neural networks and so so usually we
Define some loss function that matches
the output of the network to some
training
data uh a very typical one for the
regression is is this uh um leas squares
error and then 99% of the time we use
gradient descent to to train the network
so this is evaluating the gradient the
loss and then taking a step in the
gradient direction to to update the
weights and then I went into a little
bit more detail about how we actually do
that computationally how we actually
evaluate these gradients and to do it we
Ed the chain rule so we apply the chain
rule to the to the gradient here um and
that means evaluating the gradient of
the network with respect to the with
respect to its
parameters and um for example if we took
a fully connected Network that's just a
composition of vector functions you know
functions that output vectors and input
vectors and so we to to evaluate the
chain wall here we just have to use the
multivariate version so this is
multiplication of
jacobians but you practice we don't have
to worry about this when we're actually
doing this in pyth aual tensor flow
autod differentiation handles this and
and the back propagation algorithm is an
efficient algorithm for evaluating these
these
gradients and we're going to talk a lot
more about autoi in the second half of
the lecture series when we talk about
differentiable
physics
yeah okay yeah so by the end of this
lecture I'm going to try and explain to
you how chat GPT works at a lower level
um so instead of of uh just
understanding how we interact with it
I'll try and tell you exactly what the
the normal Network architecture is and
and the loss function that we used to
train it and you should just be able to
understand this very easily after this
lecture cool so this is the timeline
we're in the second lecture of uh
introduction to deep
learning um then on Friday this week Sid
is going to come and give you an
introduction to pdes and say why they're
so important uh to science and
scientific research and then we'll start
kind of the series the lecture Series in
Earnest and we'll be talking about our
first SEL technique which are physics
and form nor networks so that should be
really
exciting okay so what is this lecture
about um so the goal of this lecture is
to talk more about the difficulties of
training neural networks and deep neural
networks and you know it can be very
difficult to train deep neural networks
especially if the task that you're
trying to train them on is very complex
or or the loss function all the data is
very complex um and there's a lot to
think about so first I'm going to
introduce to you the concept of
overfitting and underfitting and also
how this is related to the bias and
variance of of noral networks I'll
explain what that
means then I'll talk about ways to
alleviate the underfitting and
overfitting so this is using
regularization again I'll Define what I
mean by
regularization and then we'll talk about
different types of optimizers that we
can use to train noral networks and how
the optimizer the choice of the
optimizer is a really important choice
that affects the performance of of the
network and then we'll then I'll talk
about chat GPT at the
end so yeah our learning objectives by
the end of the lecture hopefully you
will you'll understand the three main
sources of error when we're training
noral networks you'll be able to explain
over fitting underfitting and how to
alleviate it and know more about the
optimization process and the different
optimizers that we can use
okay so um so far I've just been talking
about how we train noral networks but
what I'm going to get on to is how we
test their performance and this is a
really important um difference I think
so when we train in oral Network we we
have again we have a loss function where
we're matching the output of the network
to some training data points so for
example the for regression we're trying
to train this network based on these
blue data points here the training data
uh to try and fit this polinomial to
this data
and so our training points here from a
probabilistic sense are sampled from
some joint distribution probability of X
and
Y um and we just sample end values of
those to to create our training data
set but then once we've trained the
network and we want to come to test its
performance uh we don't usually use the
same the same uh data set to to test it
what we really should do is use a test
data set um to validate the Network's
performance and this is different
different in that we don't use the same
data points to test test the uh test the
network we we sample new unseen uh
examples that the network hasn't been
trained
on um and so so we create a test data
set here and typically those samples are
sampled from the same distribution the
same underlying distribution so again
you can see the orange data points here
still follow the curve and uh we'll test
it using some other loss function it
could be the same thing so it could be
le squares but you're also free to
choose any other if you want so so we
can also have like a L1 loss for example
an AB absolute difference
instead we can also um evaluate the
train error as well using a different
metric so once we've trained it we can
again we can choose a different metric
to to evaluate the training
error so um something really interesting
happens uh when you look at the
difference between the training error
and the test error depending on the type
of network that you train on this data
um and so what I've got here is three
different neur networks that I've
trained on on this data using this
training data um on the left is a model
that has one layer and zero hidden units
and I'm using an MLP here and so that
model is just a linear model it doesn't
have an activation so it's just a matrix
and and a bias that's added to the to
the
data so you can see the model fits like
a a straight line to this this curve
obviously not a very good model it's not
very accurate and both the training loss
and test loss are quite
High um then I train a model that has
two layer 16 hidden units and you can
see this seems to do a really nice fit
it seems to fit the data very well kind
of estimates the mean of the data which
we I showed you before if you if you use
El a mean squared eror loss you
effectively um estimate the mean of this
normal
distribution um and both the train error
and test error are similar but what's
interesting is if you increase the size
of the network um the training era and
the test eror start to diverge and when
you look at the function the network
learns you can see it's a much higher
frequency function and it's really uh
very accurately fit to the training data
but not fitting to the test data very
well and we we say that this function
here is is overfitting to to our
training data so we have this gap
between our our training error and our
test
era so um from our kind of traditional
point of view we would say that this is
an overparameterized model this model
basically has too many parameters in it
it's too flexible and and can fit very
tightly to the training data and
therefore uh reduces the the the the the
test
performance so we can we can think about
uh kind of the error that the network is
making in a bit more detail and so let's
let's think about the loss function that
we're actually using to train to train
the network and like I said we use this
um Le squared error here and we have
some training data set with end points
here so more generally we say that we
train NE networks with an empirical loss
and we can write this more generally as
as uh you know the summation over all
the training data um of some loss
function so it doesn't have to be a mean
Square boss it can be any any kind of
metric here where X and Y here are
training data points are sample from our
from our joint distribution that we're
trying to model
essentially now this this isn't really
the actual loss function that we truly
want to minimize this isn't the best
thing that we can minimize to fit this
data a much better loss function to
minimize is what we call the expected
loss and so this is uh instead of just
evaluating this loss metric over over a
finite number of training points we
actually want to integrate the loss fun
the loss metric over all possible uh XY
pairs over the whole probability joint
distribution and you you can see that if
if we did this then this model will will
not over fit it will fit it will match
the Train the test data just as well as
it matches the training data because in
that integration we're sampling every
possible point every possible data
training
data so um this is impossible in
practice why why why do you think we
can't actually do why why can't we
minimize the expected cost in
practice
Yeah uh what do you mean by
computational cost
yeah yeah that's yeah that's a good one
anyone else any other
reason
yeah yeah so this so this is the main
reason actually is most of the
time uh we only have access to a finite
number of samples of this distribution
we don't actually we can't even sample
that distribution let alone comput it so
if you think of for example like natural
images we don't have every possible
natural image in the world uh we just
have a finite set that we're training
from so this this leads to what we call
um as estimation
error so this is the difference between
uh you know training a noral network on
on this empirical loss where we're only
fitting to S finite samples in this in
this distribution versus the neural
network which which would actually
minimize that expected loss and that
produces some error in in this expected
loss kind of
landscape um
there is also another source of error
can anyone tell me what the source the
other source of error
is okay so uh this is called This is
called approximation error and so
there's another reason why you even if
you minimize the expected loss here with
all the possible training points you
might not still find the function that
minimizes this metric because the normal
network is just not expressive enough to
match that
function you know if this is a really
complicated function and the Neal
Network just models the space of pols
for example just bitting pols then
you're not going to find the true
minimizer of this expected
loss so you have uh approximation error
which is the limited exclusivity of of
the noral network so so these are the
two big error sources that we need to
think about that will lead to
underfitting and
overfitting so the a really nice way to
think about this is to uh think about
the placing the noral networks that we
train inside a function space and so
this is just a pictorial representation
of a of of the space of all possible
functions that take some real input
vector and output some other real input
output vector and so you can plot uh
these different functions in this in
this space and it's it's useful to think
of it so so we can plot for example this
is the true function this star here is
the true function that we're trying a
model um and maybe it lies on some
manifold maybe it's like a polinomial or
or some sort of manif folder
functions um and then what I'm drawing
here in this blue boundary is the space
of possible functions that the neural
network can represent so you know if you
vary all if you vary the
weights this is the this is the uh space
of functions that that Network could
represent so it could be the space of
polinomial it could be the space of
linear models or or more complex non
nonlinear
models so the approximation error says
that the Network's never going to be
able to model a function that's out
outside of that area and so you know
this is the approximation area here is
the difference between the true function
and the boundary point where where that
uh where that normal Network sits but
then it's that's just the approximation
error the estimation error is the fact
that we're not minimizing the expected
loss and we have some error that we in
the finite the of the training data that
we're that we're using so this these are
the two kind of error error
sources so then we can plot these three
different models that I trained um in
this using this function space to help
you understand what it looks like um
so what I'm doing here is plotting the
space of networks possible so remember I
just trained a set of linear models here
so this is quite a small area in the
function space and that area is far away
from the the function so we can see that
we're not going to we're going to have
quite a high error in this
case um in the overfit case we have a
model that's way that's
overparameterized that can model many
types of function
and so then we may encapsulate the true
function but the network then minimizes
the empirical loss with the finite
training data uh is is maybe very far
away so the ideal model is is is a model
where we just restrict the function
space enough that we we can capsulate
the function we want to model but it's
not too big that we we are susceptible
to overfitting or you know um yeah that
the the the minimizer being too far away
okay so so hopefully you understand the
kind of error sources that lead to
overfitting and
underfitting and what I'm going to try
and do now is explain this from a more
probabilistic Viewpoint and we can kind
of um decompose this expected loss and
show you that and show you how
overfitting and underfitting kind of
emerges from this
decomposition um so what I'm going to do
is I'm first just going to Define this
function h a function of X and and d and
d is our training
data um which is just the train neural
network so it's a network after training
it's just a function that depends on X
and the training data so you can think
of I've just replaced Theta with d here
that that makes sense because D Theta
just depends on d uh you know we use
some complicated algorithm to get Theta
but the input the thing that determines
what theer is is d
um and what we'd like to understand now
is the expected loss so again this this
loss metric um the expected value of it
not just over all the training uh data
not just over all the possible inputs
and outputs but also over all the
possible data sets so what is the
average expected loss over all possible
data sets that we could we could feed we
could feed to train the
network so to go any further we have to
we have to make some assumptions so we
just assumed that for now that uh the
metric we're using is leas squares loss
function and then you can show by and
I'm not going to do it in this slide
have a look at this link down here it
gives a full full derivation but just
just by using the properties of
expectations you can show that we can
decompose this term into these three
separate terms and we call them the bias
the variance and the irreducible
noise um so I'm going to explain each of
these three terms in a bit more detail
um this is just copied from the previous
SL
so I'm first going to talk about the
variance so what does that mean what
does that term mean and so the variance
is just the expected value of of H so
this is a particular Network trained on
a particular training data
set the expected difference between that
Network and Har so what what is har bar
so har bar here is it's okay har bar
here is the expected value of of the nor
the expect the expected value of the
output of the noral network average over
all possible training data sets so so
you can think of this as just the
average model like what what's the
average model if we trained thousands of
of networks with different sampled
training data sets what's the average
prediction so the variance is just
saying how sensitive as the output of my
network to my training data
essentially you know does this does this
difference vary a lot to my average
model or is it is it
similar okay then then let's talk about
the bias so this is H bar we know that's
the that average model um and so the
bias is is the expected value of all
possible inputs to the network um of the
average model difference between the
average model and y y bar which is the
average observation so if you look at
this this is just the the mean value of
y given some input X so this is just our
mean of for example in that polinomial
with a noisy samples is the mean of that
normal distribution and this is
essentially the best possible uh
why Y Bar is the best possible predictor
of of of the of the why why random Val
variable itself you can't beat this if
you're using a at least squared
loss and and so then the final term is
this irreducible noise it's the
difference between the the true value of
the random variable and and the its mean
value and we can't we can't beat
this so so what do we want to do what
what we really want to do is make this
expected uh expected loss averaged
overall TR data sets to be as close to
zero as
possible you know we want all of our
models to train very very well that's
the that's the
goal well what we typically find um when
we evaluate this for like particular NE
networks and particular tasks is there's
most usually a Biance variant a bias
variance tradeoff and so this is this is
the statistical way of saying we there's
a trade-off between overfitting and
underfitting um so what we what we find
is um the bias and the variance depend
on the model complexity so model
complexity is the number of parameters
that we're using to train train the
network and if we have a very small
number of of parameters so for example
just linear models for example what we
usually find is that the the variance is
very low so so those models the output
of those models don't depend much on on
our training data but the bias is very
high so the average model error is is is
very high you know they don't fit the
data very well
and as we increase model complexity we
get this tradeoff where the variance
starts to increase so it becomes very
sensitive to the training data and the
buyas starts to drop so our average
model does give a very good fit to the
to the
data so our goal is to try and find some
sweet spot in the Middle where we have
you know low low bias that's basically
this is where we have low test low good
test performance and good training
performance and
so yeah if so if I go back to these
three models again the model on the left
has high bias and low
variance um again we could you could
think of sampling lots of different
training data sets from from this curve
and the linear model is always going to
fit in the same place more or less so
it's going to have low variance but High
bias this model has low bias and high
variance like this is very sensitive to
the training data because it can fit the
train data very well and then in the
middle we have this sweet spot in the in
the bias VAR
curve and in a in a kind of handwavy way
I mean this is not the definition of
these these values but you could when
you're training nor networks practically
you can some it's useful to think as the
training loss is the bias and the
difference between the test and training
loss is the variance but that's that's
not a mathematically precise
definition
okay so hopefully you understand uh what
overfitting underfitting is and and kind
of the the how we how it occurs and the
error sources behind it so now I'm going
to spend most of the rest of the lecture
talking about how we can alleviate
overfitting and underfitting um and
different yeah different ways to do that
so there there are basically some
general strategies that you need to do
if you're in a high bias or underfitting
regime or if you're in a high varience
and overfitting
regime so if you're underfitting uh the
quickest way to improve the both the
test loss and the training loss is to is
to increase the model complexity so add
more parameters to your network and make
it be able to model a more complex non
nonlinear
function um and so this if you think
about function spaces is like growing
the function space outwards alternativ
you can choose a new architecture design
or or try and shift that function space
uh to to closer to the true function
that you're trying to
model if you're overfitting if it's the
other if it's the other case um then one
way to reduce so fitting is to increase
the amount of training data you have
this effectively reduces the dependence
of the Network's output on the training
data or you do some sort of
regularization and that's what I'm going
to talk about more in the next couple of
slides is is regularizing neural
networks so let's let's think about let
me let me explain what regular
regularization
is um so we're going to think about this
regime where we have a newal network
architecture that very flexible and
tends to overfit our
data um and so what we do when we
regularize a deep network is instead of
changing the the expressivity of the
network um so the size of the the
function space what we try and do in
regularization is to try and uh prefer
certain regions of that function space
over other
regions so what regularization does is
it says um I want to prefer that the
network converges on on a on a function
that is close to the true function and
we we have to somehow guide the network
to to to close it to the to the tree
function so you can think of
regularization as like a as a soft
constraint so instead of you know a hard
constraint which changes the boundaries
of the space it just changes which which
parts of the space we prefer to converge
up or
others okay so the definition of regular
regularization is to restrict the space
of possible functions uh so we so
changing the function space could also
be thought of as regularization as well
um or preferring certain regions of the
function space or or also in a
problemistic sense it's it's imparting a
prior on our on our on our neural
network or our learning algorithm to
prefer certain Solutions already before
we've trained the
network so um I've got a little task you
so I want you to have a quick
conversation with with your neighbor um
and just think about the different ways
that you know that we could regularize a
neural network so there are actually
many many ways to regularize and just
have a brainstorm and then then I'll ask
you some some of the ways you would
thought that you thought of so you've
got you've got two two or three
minutes okay so lots of good
discussion so can anyone raise their
hand and just give me give me some of
the regularization methods that you you
talked about
yeah okay can you be more
specific yeah retrogression yeah okay so
I'm going to talk about that next that's
good y anyone
else there was a lot of
conversation y say again drop out yeah
so this is um randomly dropping some of
the activations of the network I'm going
to explain that y That's one yeah any
more so changing the loss function
changing the
architecture okay so I've got a whole
list and and hopefully you're going to
learn that there's lots of different
ways to do it and and it's not just
about these these new two ones that you
proposed so
um here's just some ways of regularizing
or networks so so um the hard the hard
constraint versions is where we're
changing this function space so you know
we'll change the boundaries of the
function Space by reducing the model
complexity or changing the nor
architecture to shift that function
space as
well um another way to regularize is to
increase the amount of training data
like reduce the dependency of the of of
the network on the training data and
that is just naturally going to bring
you know we already learned that that's
going to bring our um minimizer closer
to the true
function um we can do we weight
regularization so this is adding terms
in the loss function for example uh or
more generally we can add additional
loss terms we can do Dropout as you
mentioned another type of regularization
is early stopping I'm going to I'm going
to explain what that means
later so I'm going to go through each of
these in the list and talk about them in
a bit more
detail so let's talk about weight
regularization it's it's a very simple
idea and it's to say well we know that
overparameterized networks tend to
overfit overfit the data so so that's
just add a soft term in the loss
function that um just tries to minimize
the the L2 Norm of the weights so what
is it saying it's saying I prefer
weights that are close to zero rather
than large values and and you can think
of that as asserting some prior that the
network learns to prune unnecessary
connections so it you know it makes
itself a leaner model as it trains and
and this can help
overfitting so also known as
retrogression and we can use other other
Norms like an L1 Norm or in l z nor
depending on the type of type of
regression um I I like to compare this
uh you know have a probabilistic
perspective on this on this thing as
well it's it's quite interesting to
interpret it and um when we're doing
regression I I talked about this in the
last lecture um what we're really trying
to do is estimate this conditional
distribution you know the the
probability of Y given the value of x um
and we assume that it was a normal
normal distribution and I showed in in
the last lecture that if we use maximum
likelihood estimation on on this dist on
this distribution uh we can derive the
Le squared error loss function so we can
derive this this loss function so we we
can actually also derive this loss
function if we if we change kind of the
the assumptions in in that
derivation so I'm just going to go
through it again and so we say that the
data likelihood here is the probability
of all of our data points you know all
the X1 X X2 y1 Y2 given our Theta values
if we assume in
um independent identically distributed
training examples we can write it as
just this product of of each of each
conditional
value so now what's different to before
is we actually assume a prior on the
parameters of the network so we say
without knowing anything about the
training data we we assume that the the
value of the parameter or the
distribution of parameters is is a
normal distribution so the parameters
are distributed over some normal
distribution with mean of zero and some
standard
deviation so so then we can say just
using base rule the the the probability
of the the parameters given the data set
is just is just base rule um which
depends on this prior here and uh the
probability of the data given the the
parameters so the data likelihood and so
This this term here is the posterior of
the parameters posterior
distribution and so instead of doing
maximum likely ES estim where where we
we maximized the probability of the data
we maximize this term what we do instead
is we use maximum a posterior estimation
so map estimation to maximize the
probability of theta given the data so
they kind of the other way around this
allows us to incorporate this prior into
our into our into our
estimation so you can just you can write
this uh uh uh posterior distribution
down here or at least the top top ter
here and the B we can't in general
estimating the probability of the data
can be very complicated but it's just a
normalizing term so we don't actually
need to compute it in this just for
doing map estimation so so uh to
maximize the posterior is just
maximizing this this object and and you
can see that that's also equivalent to
to to um to minimizing this loss
function which we we stated at the
start so it's kind of a nice nice just
probalistic interpretation of of doing
weight regularization
okay so we don't just have to use uh you
know this specific additional term in
the loss function we're free to choose
kind of any additional terms that we
want in the in the loss function so in
general the loss function can have some
regularizer that tries to push the the
Network's out solution to some preferred
solution so there are many examples and
they depend on the task that you want to
train the network to do so for example
if I'm doing something like image
generation I'm using a generative
Network to to produce images one one
possible um one possible regularizing
term is the structural similarity index
measure so this is kind of an empirical
kind of horis that that compares two
images together and it just and and it's
it's known as like a perceptual image
quality measure so it's it's uh it tries
to place a high weight on images that
look natural I won't go into why these
memes and standard deviations do that
but that's this is a very common
metric if you're if you're training
neural networks to do to model like
frequen like a certain frequency band of
of some data so for example in
scientific research we we sometimes want
to do that um we might want to have some
preference over the types of frequencies
that the network outputs and so this
this additional loss term could take for
example the output of the network it
could maybe for transform it to get its
frequency components and then put a you
know put a high loss on higher value
higher frequency components for
example you can even have some way more
uh sophisticated loss functions for
example feature space losses and so we
don't just have to have a loss in this
in this in the space of the the vector
space of the output of the network we
can transform that output to some other
um by a nonlinear transformation into
some other Vector space and do a kind of
a ukian distance in that
space so for example we can have a a
feature space loss if we if we want um
for example if these are two images and
we want them to match in their Salient
representations of those images rather
than the pixel space of that image we
can have like a CNN this could be for
example in those unsupervised models
that have some latent Vector we could
pass the the output of the network
through that that uh feature model to
get those latent representation and then
match match the training data point to
the output of the model in that in that
latent
representation and that's a that's a
really nice trick that that can improve
performance as well and
so so in in summary there are many
different L loss terms that we can
use okay and then uh what you mentioned
was Dropout so this is another really
popular technique for regularizing
neural
networks and so we're not changing the
loss function here but what we're doing
is we're changing the neural network
every training step that we that we do
when we're training that we're training
the
network so as we're training what we do
is we just randomly set some of the
activations of of the network to zero so
for example in the first training step
we might just throw away the activation
from from uh this neuron from this
neuron and from this neuron we'll just
switch them off and we'll back propagate
through the network and update just
based on the connections that
highlighted then when we go to the next
the next training step we'll we'll
randomly drop other activations so maybe
it will be this one this one and this
one so as we're going through we're just
dropping dropping the dropping random
activations so why why does this
regularize the network why does it
improve uh the the performance of the
network well in a kind of loose sense
what it's doing is it's saying uh you
know the output of the network here
shouldn't depend too strongly on like
any specific um the output of any
specific
norn um or equivalently individual
norons here shouldn't depend too
strongly on on it on their pre on a
single previous noron that it's
connected to
um and this this can really help the
network learn like a like a a
generalized representation that doesn't
depend too strongly on like a specific
input um what we're actually doing
really is effectively training on
Ensemble of Ensemble of models where
each model has like a random random set
of Connections in in the
network um and you can go much further
into uh kind of mathematically
interpreting Dropout and you can show
that this is actually uh estimating the
uh the uncertainty on the on the
Network's outputs so if you sample uh
after you train the network if you if
you sample from many different uh many
different members of this Ensemble you
can get an uncertainty estimation so how
how what is the variance between the
predictions of the of the
network so if you're interested in drop
out have a have a look more about on
this reference this yeah very very good
technique okay uh the next
regularization method that is also used
a lot in practice is is early stopping
and so what I'm showing here is this
overparameterized network uh that you
know eventually overfits to the data and
gives us a a poor poor
generalization what I'm showing is how
it evolves the network prediction
evolves over training step and it's very
interesting to plot you know the
convergence or the the test era and the
training era as a function of training
step
here and what you see is they start off
a very similar value this is because
that the Network's prediction to start
off with is very smooth it's almost a
linear
function and then as it trains there's
some point at which they diverge really
strongly but somewhere in the middle we
actually are in this regime where we
have low test error low training error
um and we have like a nice nice nice
performing
model um and so this is called early
stopping that uh you know if we just
stop the training algorithm here rather
than continuing for more iterations we
would get this nice smooth model that
that fits the data world
so it's really interesting to study why
that is the case like why does why why
does the network halfway through through
training have like a nice smooth
approximation and at least for fully
connected networks there's this property
which is known as spectral bias and this
is exactly this property where they tend
to learn low frequencies in the data
much much faster than high frequencies
in the data and this can just be a nice
already a nice built-in regularizer of
the network and it and it's maybe the
reason why you know overparameterized
deep network still generalize nicely uh
and interpolate between your training
data ones because they tend to fit like
a nice low frequency approximation to
start
with we're going to talk about spectral
bias uh when we talk about physics and
form nor networks and actually that's
that uh reduces the performance of
physics and formal networks so that's
going to be an interesting discussion in
that in that
lecture okay and then uh the final way
of regularizing uh deep networks um
which is often the best way if you can
do it is is just to increase the amount
of training data you have like make it
really hard for the network to overfit
the data by having as many possible
samples of that distribution that we're
trying to model as
possible um so how do we do that the
question is uh as you mentioned uh how
do we do that if we only have access to
a few samples from that joint
distribution uh we don't have the data
to to improve and so there are a lot of
there are a lot of tricks to augment or
change our training data to to try and
get around
this so let's imagine this situation
where we're gonna We want to train an or
network here to do some digit
classification so we have you know an
image of a digit and we want to produce
a classification what number is that
digit but let's just assume that we only
have nine images so this is a really
dangerous situation we're g to if I
trained a CNN on this on this data set
here I guarantee you that it would over
fit very quickly um and it wouldn't it
wouldn't perform well if I gave it a new
digit that it hasn't seen
before so one there there are a couple
of strategies that we can take um to try
and improve the performance the first
strategy is just to augment the training
data set and so this is to change the
inputs um by some some transformation
and keep the same label and train the
network to learn across those
Transformations so for example we might
do some like random rotations we might
add noise to the to the images and any
way to try try and change that uh input
image so that the network learns over a
more varied range of
inputs this can kind of a nice upside of
this is it means the network can be more
resilient to like noise and other other
kind of um perturbations and the inputs
in in real world data it can be very
useful if if you another way to do it um
which is also very popular is is to is
to do a pre-training step so it's and
what we sometimes call this
self-supervised learning and so what
this means is before we train the
network to do the classification task
we're going to pre-train it to do some
other task beforehand which hopefully
trains the network to learn some like
feature representation uh that is useful
for the main task that we actually want
to
Sol so for example we might this is the
classification uh Network this uh
decoder for example uh sorry encoder we
might attach a decoder to to that
network uh and then use a lost function
a nonsupervised loss function that tries
to reconstruct uh uh the input image for
example and in doing so this this
network here will learn like a latent
representation or like a Salient
representation that is useful then once
to to train it afterwards on the
classification
task so it could just be a
reconstruction loss it could also be uh
we could do other types of loss
functions so we can randomly like take
out some of the data in the input and
try and get the network to predict the
predict the answer um and so all of
these all of these methods these These
are self-supervised methods that
pre-train the network to to help it
generalize on just these few
images so this is kind of known as like
one shot or few shot learning after
after pre-training the
network okay so uh I've talked a lot
about regularization so we'll take a
break and then we'll move on move on
thank
you okay so we talked about over fitting
underfitting um then we tried to uh talk
about ways to alleviate both of those by
by using regularization um and I talked
about many different regularization
techniques hopefully you've learned a
few
more um so now I'm going to talk about
the final part of this lecture which is
optimizing deepal networks and the fact
that the optimizer that we choose has a
massive impact in the performance of of
the
network and we should have time to talk
about uh chat GPT at the end
so we talked about these two sources VAR
the the um approximation error so
whether the fact whether the noral
network is expressive enough to model
the true function and also the
estimation error which is the
sensitivity of the of the train Network
to the towards training data and the
fact that we're not minimizing this true
expected
loss but there is one other kind of
elephant in the room or one other big
source of error that can mean that the
function that we train is not the true
function
um and this is optimization error and
you know up until now I've just been
assuming that you know when we train the
oral Network we end up with the
parameters that actually do minimize
this empirical loss that is the true
minimizer of this loss
function but in practice uh you know
finding the global minimum of this
function is incredibly hard and I would
argue we don't do it for pretty much
every noral Network we
train um and so when we're talking about
error
the error of the function that the
network models we also had to consider
the effect of optimization error and
this is this is a big part of the these
these eror
sources so it's kind of uh you know I I
motivated nor networks last start of
last lecture by saying they have this
Universal approximation Theory know in
theory they can approximate any function
but that function doesn't say anything
about how easy it is to find that
function how you know whether we can
actually optimize this function to to
get that
function so let's go back to our our
function space um and now I'm plotting
all three all three error sources these
are the three error sources that we we
have to consider when we're training all
networks so again we have our our true
function here we have our space of
possible functions the network can
represent here approximation eror is the
you know is the
closest Network function in that space
that is closest to the true function
error is this extra error from the
training
data and then optimization error here is
the fact that we're not minimizing the
empirical loss or we're not finding the
global minimum of that empirical loss
we're finding some other other location
in the loss function so we have an extra
error
to
okay so how do we eleviate each of these
three so I already talked about the top
sorry I talked about the top two uh
approximation error we just increase the
size of the Blue Area increase the
hypothesis space estimation error uh you
know use regularization or or if we have
training data add more training
data optimization error we have to
improve the optimizer make the optimizer
more able to find the global minimum of
the loss
function so when you're training noral
networks and and you see that your test
performance is poor then my advice is to
go through each of these individually
and think am I you know do I have a
flexible enough function do I have
enough training data overfitting and can
I improve the optimization process these
are the kind of big three questions that
you want to be asking
yourself so let's let's actually look at
the Lost landscape so this is a this was
a really uh uh interesting paper um and
it's very simple what they did is is
they they tried to visualize the the
Lost landscape and this is actually
quite difficult to do like this this
loss function here is a function of
theta and Theta is often you know
millions of values of we're training a
deep n network so just to visualize the
loss function in this very high
dimensional space is actually quite hard
to
do and so what they did is a trick to be
able to see it in 2D and to plot so this
is a this is an actual lost landscape of
an
network and to create this plot uh what
they did is they sampled randomly two
two vectors in this space in the in the
space of weights of the network so in
this High dimensional parameter space so
you just randomly randomly sample to two
vectors and then you plot instead of the
the full the full loss landscape you
just plot the loss value um varied
across those two vectors so uh this this
function
here so you're obviously not visualizing
the whole loss landscape here but we can
see it across like one plane this
essentially we're just looking at across
plane of the plane in a plane in the
space um and uh yeah this is really
interesting to look at so this is a real
lost surface from from a reset trained
on CCI far so so this is these are
natural images and I think it was a
classification task so know this is a
this is a nor Network in the wild and
what you see is this um this lost
landscape is incredibly complex so we
have you know we have like a a global
Minima here so so by the way this is
centered around where the optimizer
landed after the network train so so you
can see that it landed in this in this
Minima here actually it might not be the
global Minima it might just be a local
Minima we don't not sure but it's
surrounded by these valleys and troughs
and you can see how it'd be very
difficult to try try and find you know a
better minimizer if if you if you're
inside one of these values for
example okay so this is the issue is the
loss function is very high dimensional
and contains many local Minima in in
practice so um I'm going to talk about
difficulties or challenges of optimizing
nor nwork and and there are actually
many many reasons why the loss function
can be very hard to
optimize um and the first one is kind of
counterintuitive is there actually a lot
of um uh times when the loss function is
completely flat so instead of instead of
looking like this uh the loss function
is just flat everywhere and that's a
real big problem when we're training nor
networks because we're evaluating the
gradient of the Lost function to to
update the weights and if the Lost
function is flat then we're not going to
move anywhere the algorithm's going to
isn't going to optimize the
network so why is this the case why do
we get uh this is SOC called Vanishing
gradient so the gradient just TS to zero
everywhere why why does this happen in
in normal networks when we're training
them so uh this is the problem that the
Lost function the gradient of the Lost
function is zero so so um I'm going to
give you a clue here I'm going to say
that we're
using MLP so a fully connected Network
and we're going to use this tanning H
activation function here so can anyone
think of a reason why why the Lost
function might go to the gradient of the
Lost function might go to zero if we use
these 10 activations
the derivative of what this
really yeah yeah I think You' got it
yeah so so uh when X is very um well
when the magnitude of X is very large so
if it's very negative or very positive T
H has this property which we call
saturation basically where the the
activation saturates and it just gives a
value of one no matter what the value of
x is so in in in if if we if we give it
an an input Vector here that's not
approximately within minus one to one
then the output of the activation isn't
going to depend uh on the input
anymore and yeah if you just look at the
function you can see the gradient over
here is is zero and when we evaluate the
gradient theost function with effect to
the parameters we're applying the chain
wall remember and at some point in that
chain wall we're going to need to
evaluate the the derivative of L
function um this is like an intermediate
intermediate um output of the network
and it's going to be zero so it's just
going to you know zero out the entire
gradient the gradient of the L
function so this is really important
point that is often very much overlooked
it's one of the bugs that always happens
when you train networks is we forget to
normalize our our inputs and our outputs
so we want to make sure that the network
sees inputs that approximately between
minus one and one and and sees also sees
outputs that are between minus one and
one and this is really good practice and
even if you're not using T activation
functions it's definitely recommended to
to do
that okay so let's just imagine now that
we've properly um normalized our inputs
and outputs so we're not saturating our
activation functions um we can still get
this problem of Vanishing gradients that
the the output of the network or or the
loss function can still be
flat so what we need to think about um
is how the how the values of the of the
of the outputs of each layer vary as we
go through the network as we get deeper
and deeper through the
network so let's just think about the
output of a single neuron we're gonna
we're going to make it very simple and
not think about we're going to not have
an activation function and it's just
going to be an
MLP and so that that single noron in
that in that case is just taking its
input vector or timesing it by its
weights and and and it's just a straight
linear model basically
so then then we make a couple of more
assumptions and we just say these inputs
to the to the neuron are just random
random
variables let's say that the weight
weight values themselves are also random
variables and therefore Y is also like a
you know a computed random variable um
that is a function of these
two so then the variance of Y here is
just the variance of this object and if
you make a couple more assumptions like
for example each of the input elements
are independent and identically
distributed in the same with the weights
um you can show again just by basic
properties of the the variance of random
variables uh the the variance of Y is is
the variance of x times by the variance
of of the weight Times by the number of
inputs so the number of number of X
elements that we're suming
together
okay so uh what I'm going to show here
is how the choice of the variance of the
weights so so how initialize the weights
really affects uh how the variance of Y
evolves through the network so how yeah
how how the output values
vary so what what what is plotted in
here um is the outputs of each layer of
just a fully connected Network so this
is a network that has five five layers
and this distribution here is just
showing you the range of values the each
uh each um layer outputs basically
so uh we're going to assume that the the
the input to the network starts with
like uh you know this this range of
values between approximately minus one
and one and then as the as the network
as we as we pass the vector through the
network those those those range of
values decreases or
increases so what we're applying here
are three different networks the first
network has the weight values drawn from
a normal distribution with a mean of
zero and and a standard deviation of
0.05
this one has a l weights drawn from a
larger value of standard deviation and
then this one from an even larger value
of standard
deviation and what's important is that
this MLP um each layer has 100 hidden
units so we're we're taking the the
input which we're assuming is also 100
values producing an output which has 100
values so we know from this expression
that uh you know the variance of y
equals a number of inputs so 100 in this
case Times by The variance of weights
Times by The variance of
X so um it's really important to choose
the variance of the weights so that we
approximately keep these uh you know the
the range of values approximately the
same between minus one and
one and just from this mathematical
equation we can see that you know if if
our weights are initialized with a
variance that's less than one over the
number of
inputs we start getting this exponential
decrease of the of the outputs of the of
the network so you know no matter what
the is here eventually if we have enough
layers the output of the network is
always going to tend towards zero which
is a really bad situation like we want
the output to be between minus one and
one
uh conversely if we chose that the
variance of the weights is greater than
this one over n uh then we see the
opposite effect but the outputs
exponentially grow and they explode so
this is known as Vanishing and this is
known as exploding
exploding um so this is The Sweet Spot
is where we choose we initialize our
weights so that the variances you know
one over the number of inputs of of the
neuron and you can see how this would
you know this this bottom case and the
top the bottom case and the top case
would would result in zero would result
in the Lost function being zero or the
gradient of the Lost function being zero
because if all output values are zero
then the Lost functions going be zero
and um if all output values tend to
Infinity then if you're using tan
activation functions you're going to
start saturating that 10 H and you'll
get the effect that I just talked about
before so yeah initializing the network
in this way it's known as Lan
initialization and I think it's the
default in py torch when you use a a
linear layer that could be one but I
think it's
true um so you can do the same thing so
I talked about thinking about how the
outputs of the network evolve uh over
each layer of the network you can also
think about the back propagation when
we're back propagating the gradient
backwards through the network in in
backrop and we can carry out the same
type of analysis so remember we just use
the chain rule so we say uh you know DL
by DX is DL by Dy Dy by DX where you
know this is an intermediate layer with
this layer function here and you can do
the same thing where you assume that
these gradients are random and uh know
random variables um and and do the same
variance analysis on on what we ECT the
the gradient um with respect to the
inputs compared to the gradient with
respect to the outputs of the layer so
you know one step after the one step in
the gr descent
algorithm and this actually gives the
the kind of opposite result that the
variance of the weight should be one
over the another of outputs of the
neuron rather than one over the number
of inputs to the
neuron it's kind of interesting to think
the the the stability is different
depending on if we're going forwards
through the network or backwards through
the
network and so we have to choose some
sort of compromise and and a good common
compromise is is this harmonic mean when
we're initializing the weights so it's
yeah the harmonic mean of of those two
two initialization strategies so this is
called zavier
initialization okay so continuing that
Trend to make what we really want to
make sure like I said before is that you
know the outputs of each layer tend or
tend to stay within the range minus one
to one it's really important to make
sure that the loss function is well well
behaved um another way to do that
instead of choosing our weights to make
sure that that is um insured another way
to do it is to dynamically make sure
that the outputs of each Network are in
a Range minus one to one and this is
batch normalization so what we do
typically when we're evaluating a n
network we don't just give it a single
input we give it a batch of inputs
especially when we're doing stochastic
gradient descent I'll talk about that in
a
minute and so
what we say is in this batch Norm layer
um we just take statistics of that batch
and we then we normalize the outputs of
the layer based on those statistics so
so we take the mean of the uh mean of
the output value across the batch in the
standard deviation of the of the output
value across the batch which are just
these two computations here and then we
normalize the output of the layer based
on that mean and that standard deviation
here so you can see that this object
here would be normalized between minus
one and one approxim
um we also have when we do batch
normalization we have a couple of
learnable parameters that we introduce
so this this gamma and beta here um and
they're learnable parameters they're
initialized again between zero minus one
and one but they can vary and and it
just gives the the the layer the
opportunity to undo the normalization if
if it desires to if the if the learning
algorithm thinks that that's a good idea
um so this actually changed the
architecture of the network itself it's
not just a um an initialization strategy
and so this is batch Norm is also often
thought about as a regularization
strategy which is actually really
interesting to kind of understand that
in more
detail the only other thing is once we
train the network and we come to test it
we should best practice is to fix these
values we don't want to keep varing them
depending on the inputs that we give the
network and so we usually keep running
estimates of these means and standard
ation for for the test time inference in
the
network
yeah um Epsilon here is just to make
sure it's numerically stable so it's
very it's like oh yes Precision one to
the minus 12 or
something okay so another way to uh to
make sure that especially the gradients
when we're talking about the gradient
stability and that the gradients don't
vanish as we're back propagating through
the the network is to use residual
Connections in the network and this is
kind of the idea of of reset
um so what is a residual correction or
residual connection um it's also known
as skip connections it's very simple
idea it's to say um we have some input
to the layer here x and instead of
saying that the output of the of the
layer is just you know the the output of
this layer function whatever it is with
some fre parameters of the of the
network we're going to say that the
output of the layer is the value of this
layer function plus the original value
of x so you know this is the full layer
function here it's the original value of
x the input plus the plus the flexible
function that we're
learning so in this way you can see that
the this layer is learning a correction
of X rather than learning a full full
change of the vector it's learning to
add some correction term to that to that
input
Vector now if you do this and you think
about back propagating through this
function so for example what is the
derivative of L with respect to X um
again use the chain rule um and we can
just show that it's the derivative of L
with respect to Y Times by this this
object
here and if if the layer function is
zero so the if the network doesn't done
anything uh this term is zero and we
just still end up with the the gradient
before we applied the before we applied
the function so so the backrop will
still have a gradient going through that
that layer even if the layer is the
output of this function is
zero so this really kind of neat idea
and it's it's very effective in practice
um what one cool kind of property of
resets is um you can train a reset with
like hundreds of layers the gradient is
going to flow nicely through it and at
some point the resinet is going to uh uh
learned that it has enough layers and it
will just set the later layers to zeros
or at least that's the idea I don't know
if in practice that actually is how it
works but uh you can think of it as kind
of learning the ideal depth of the
network um resonet also in practice
really really good for tasks where you
know the input to the network is similar
to the output that you're trying to get
the network to to learn so for example
if I'm doing something like image Den
noising the input to the network is like
a noisy image and the output is
the The Noise free image depending on
the characteristics of the noise that
might look quite similar and and so the
reset with the residual connections is
going to learn just the noise
component there's also a really deep
connection with with of resets with um
OD solvers and uh you know this layer
function here starts to look a bit like
a a single step in a in an Oiler step
for example in od solvers um I'm going
to talk about this a lot more when we
talk about hybrid work flows and noral
differential equations in the in the
last half of the of the of the lecture
course so yeah so this is what you know
this is the original reset paper they
they were able to train really really
deep models with with stable gradient
flow backwards all the way through the
to the to the
inputs um and they did show in the paper
that um you know if we use residual
connections here we can start we can
improve the test performance with a
deeper Network and and that can be
harder if we don't have residual
connections so here without the residual
connections um the deepen or network is
performing uh not as well and that may
be because it's harder you know you have
it's harder to back propagate through
the gradients and keep them stable as
you training the
network another really common uh type of
resal network that we use especially
especially for scientific uh research so
this is called uh the un uh this was
proposed for Medical
Imaging and it's just a convolutional
network um where each convolution it
downscales the image uh to some very low
dimensional space here and then upscales
it again to give you your final image
but each scale or like intermediate
scale that we're Computing we have add a
skip Connection in the unet so we have
this kind of unet shape
here um so this network is really
interesting it kind of learns learns
across different scales and and learn
residual differences between the inputs
and turns out that that's really good at
doing segmentation of of many different
types of images
actually okay so I talked a lot about
Vanishing gradients and making sure that
the loss function um is an appropriate
loss function to
optimize and you know initializing the
network using batch Norm uh using resets
to to make sure that that's the case so
now I'm going to talk about the actual
optim ER that we use to train the new
network you know to update the
weights and I said you know 99% of the
time we we use gradient descent to to
train the Neal Network and so let's just
recap what gradient descent is again we
have our loss function here we
initialize our weights randomly but
making sure that their variance is
appropriate for the you know the size of
the of the the of the
layers we compute the gradient the loss
loss function and then we just update
the weights by taking a small step in in
that grade in Direction and Gamma her is
our learning rate typically we set that
to a small a small number so we take a
small a small step in in that
direction so you can visualize let's
just imagine we have two two free
parameters that we're learning here so
we can actually plot the Lost
landscape and we might start start
somewhere here for example and the we
just follow the gradient dection uh
gradient descent
Direction so you can see immediately
like a standard out the box gradient
descent is always going to get stuck in
in in any local minimo that it's going
to find it's once it's got to this local
Minima here it's it's not going to be
able to go upwards because it always
follows the gradient
downwards so in practice there are a lot
of kind of tricks or improvements to the
standard grad descent algorithm that we
use to to be able to discover you know
the actual uh you know better better
minimizers of this loss
function um so one way to do it is uh
just to use a larger learning
rate so even though we're following the
grading direction if we if we get here
for example the gradient is going to
point us towards this local Minima but
that local Minima might be very small
and narrow and if we take a larger step
size we might just jump over that local
Minima and land into a different area of
the loss function that will then
eventually take us to to maybe a better
Minima of the
loss so this works to some extent um you
know we can escape local Minima
but the problem is that we can also
Escape other Global minimal or better
performing parts of the Lost function
too so you know if the learning rate is
big enough we might also Escape out of
this this area as well so it can be very
unstable and and so one trick to kind of
uh to counteract this is to use an
exponentially decaying or or a slowly
reducing learning rate so it has some
kind of exploration phase where it's
bumping around the Lost function
exploring the whole space and then it
slowly Narrows in and kind of end to the
solution uh there are other tricks that
you can do with the size of the step so
you can have so-called adaptive learning
rates or intelligent learning rates and
so we what we do here is we adapt the
step size that we take depending on the
state the state of the optimizer or
maybe the context that uh the optimizer
has of the Lost landscape around it so
for example you can adapt the learning
rate based on for example how large the
gradient is the local curvature how fast
learning is happening how quickly the
Lost function is decreasing for
example the values of the weights there
there are many different many different
approaches um so another really really
popular method which is used in the
majority of of cases when training newal
networks is to use stochastic gradient
descent or also known as minib batch
gradient descent
um and so what we do here is we you know
we use the same same loss function um
but instead of evaluating this loss
function over our entire training data
set so all of our training
examples we only evaluate the loss
function using a random batch of
training examples so a much smaller
number of much smaller number of
examples um you might think based on our
previous discussion oh we making the
train data set even smaller we're going
to like really over fit this isn't
actually the case um helps to helps the
optimizer in many cases by making this
gradient estimation noisy of the true
gradient of the loss
function because we're not we're not
getting the gradient of the True Value
over all the training examples we won't
take a necessarily a step in the true
gradient direction we might just take
some random deviation from it and so
this this noisy gradient estim helps us
again bump around the the loss function
and an escape local
Minima and in practice is actually very
good at getting us towards better
Solutions um so yeah I really recommend
this is your kind of default Choice when
you're training deep noral networks um
it produces noisy gradient estimates so
that we can escape local Minima um it's
the other one just sole Reason by itself
is this is much more efficient generally
than than using full batch training so
you know if I'm training a noral network
to classify images and I have image net
like I don't want to evaluate the
gradient with respect to all of my
training data that could be millions of
examples and and just be way too
computation expensive so we can get away
with like batch sizes of hundreds rather
than Millions when we're training images
for
example and yes it's a why wiely use in
practice um so the the optimizer that is
basically the I would say the default
choice of most people these days for
training deep networks is the Adam
Optimizer and so Adam is just a very of
of gradient descent and it can also be
used stochastic gradient descent using
mini batches as
well and so how is Adam different from
standard gradient descent um it's it's
very simple uh this is how the algorithm
Works
um uh it's again you're looping you're
estimating the gradient in
looping but to estimate the step the
direction that you're stepping in you
you first compute the gradient of the
Lost
function then what you do is you um
estimate these things called The Moments
and so so what these two quantities are
is essentially keeping a running average
of the gradient um as a function of
training step here and an average a
running average of the magnitude of the
gradient so the gradient squared here uh
for for each
parameter and uh beta here is just known
as a forgetting factor it's saying how
much does this running average how much
should it depend on previous values
versus the current value of the gradient
so it's kind of like a smooth average as
we're going um as we're exploring
through our our loss landscape and
optimizing then we apply a bias
correction I I'll say what that means in
a minute um and then we update the
weights uh by taking a step in this kind
of average gradient Direction um or
running average Direction um but also
that step is normalized by the the
running average of the
magnitude okay so what why why is this
useful why is why why do we use this
um so there's basically two ideas that
make it different from gradient descent
the first is that we're keeping some
momentum when we're moving in the
parameter space like the gradient step
that we taken depends on the previous
values of the gradient because we're
taking this running average so it gives
us some momentum that if we're going
downhill we might keep that momentum in
that direction and be able to go uphill
a little bit um to escape a local Min
for
example the second idea is to adapt the
step size so this is an Adaptive
algorithm
based on the magnitude of gradient and
so what this is doing essentially is is
normalizing the gradient and it's saying
that this this this step direction is
generally approximately a step of
one in the in terms of the in terms of
the parameter
value um and so here then the learning
rate is more intuitive because it
basically tells you on average um what
is the kind of the the magnitude of the
update I'm applying to the the parameter
each training
step and then the bias correction in the
that I showed in the previous slide is
just uh to remove the effect of the
initial value of the moving average so
this is just a uh yeah this is just a
Nuance of the
ALG so yeah here's here's a plot of um
Adam versus gradient descent you can
also um select you can mix and match
these so you can just you can use
gradient descent just with momentum or
gradient descent just with adap step
sizing for
example so this is a standard gradient
descent versus gradient descent with
momentum and then and then Adam so this
adaptive step sizing plus plus the
momentum
term and yeah you can see we keep some
momentum and we we are able to jump over
this bump and land in land in the global
Minima of this of this L
function
okay so yeah this is definitely the the
best starting point I would I would
recommend to use to use
Adam okay so there's one final Optimizer
that or type of optimization algorithm
that I want to talk about and these are
higher order optimization
algorithms um and so the optimizers that
we've I've been talking about so far
just been using the gradient of the loss
function um but it can be much more
powerful to use higher order uh
derivatives of the loss function to help
you explore that loss
function so we we know you know if we
take this loss function here which is
just a a Scala function of this single
weight sing Single parameter here we can
use a tailor approximation to you know
approximate this function locally around
some point hopefully you've all you all
know about the tailor tailor
series um and what we normally do is
just estimate the gradient so the first
the first order first order uh term in
this in this approximation and we use
that gradient to take a step but what we
could do instead is make a second order
ter approximation of this function uh by
using the second order derivative of the
of the loss function to fit instead of
just a straight line to this to this
function we now start fitting a a
quadratic to it
instead and then when we take a step we
don't just step in the gring direction
we actually step directly to the Minima
of that of that second order
approximation of that quadratic function
so this is Newton's method um and this
the step now depends not just on the
gradient but also the second order
derivative the curvature of the Lost
function so I mean in practice unor
networks have lots of parameters and so
the inputs to L is a is a vector rather
than a scaler and and so in general for
multivariate function we can do the same
thing but we have to use the The hessan
Matrix and this becomes to take this
step involves inverting this this hessan
of the L
function um problem with that is that
the h itself is an absolutely huge huge
Matrix um it's p by P where p is the
number of parameters so if I have a or
network which has a million parameters
the hessan Computing the hessan if we
computed it fully would be a million by
a million and that's that's a huge Ur in
a lot of
computation so this is usually
prohibitively expensive and and most
modern methods that use you know high
order optimization use some
approximation to that hessan by by
keeping like run running estimates of
the h for example I'm not going to go
into it in detail but there's for
example L lbfgs is a very very uh very
common method to do
this um and it does turn out when we're
training noral networks for example
physics and form networks high order
optimizers can can help in in these
networks okay so uh we've got five
minutes left so I'm just going to talk
about chat ubt so I promised you that by
the end of this lecture I I should be to
explain to you how chat GPT is
working um and and it um even though
it's a incredibly impressive model um
that is able to do remarkable things and
you know have full-blown conversations
with us and and uh you know even mimic
humans in some way the way that it's
trained is actually incredibly
simple um and again chat GPT is just a
noral network it's just a function that
we fit the data this function is
incredibly complex and Incredibly
but um the data that we're fitting this
function to is just some Corpus of of
text and this is a huge Corpus of text
like this is like data scraped from the
whole internet and many books and Etc
and we can think of that text as just a
sequence of tokens so you know as a
vector um where if we just took
Wikipedia for example and just wrote it
into one long sentence each word for
example might be a single element of
that vector and we would have n words in
total so you know this is the whole data
set
here and so what is the input to the
network what is the output the input to
the network is just a subsequence so
this is like for example a single
sentence this would be the question that
or the prompt that you feed
chpt and then the output of the network
what's the network actually trying to
predict it's trying to uh do a
classification so it's saying or an auto
regression it's saying you know given
this input sequence what is the next
what is the likely uh next to in that
sequence what the next
value so it's estimating this
conditional distribution you know what
is the next value given the previous
values and we use an uh we estimate that
probability distribution just is is just
the output of the network so you know
the network has a bunch has many
different output neurons and each neuron
is given a probability to say you know
if it's this neuron then it's going to
be this this this word as
output so this is standard
classification we just train this
network with standard cross entropy loss
just like I showed you in the first
lecture and this is the the loss
function that we
use um and what's remarkable is that
even though CH GPT is just training to
predict the next word uh like really
amazing properties just emerge from that
from that complicated model and that
huge amount of data that we train it on
so we can start feeding it sentences it
questions and it can answer those
questions in intelligibility and that's
that's to me that is really remarkable
that it it's able to do that and this is
socaled zero zero shot learning where
you train it on a specific prediction
task and all of a sudden it can do lots
of other tasks afterwards like add
numbers together if you ask it to add
numbers for
example um so if we want to generate
multiple tokens then we just uh uh
recursively run this network forward so
we we you know we give it a prompt we
predict the next word we append that
word to the to our prompt and then we
recursively run it forwards to get the
the full output of the of the model
okay so what is the model what's the
architecture so the architecture is this
really popular method called a
Transformer used a lot in in
state-ofthe-art research
today so I'm going to spend the last the
last two slides just telling you what an
overview of the Transformer architecture
I think Sid will talk about Transformers
a bit more later in the course um but so
this is the architecture that they that
they show in one of the early chat GPT
papers um and um it's an or Network
which has this structure it has this
block of of layers that's uh applied 12
times so it's a very deep door Network
and each block has different layer
layers within it and you already know
what most of these layers are so so you
know it has a feed forward Network here
just a fully connected network has a
skip connection here we talked about
resonance it has a layer Norm which is
just a variant of batch normalization
where instead of normalizing over the
the training inputs we're or the batch
of inputs we're normalizing over the
features over the layer so it's just a
different type of of
normalization and and the one kind of
thing that I haven't talked about so far
is this attention layer and so that's
the key kind of innovation of a
transformer this is this attention
attention
block so what is attention what is an
attention layer so I'm just going to
describe it a very high level for you um
attention is a sequence to sequence
operation so so the input to the layer
is a sequence uh of vectors the output
of the layer is another sequence of
vectors so when we're applying this
layer to text prediction which is what
chat GPT is doing um the input is like a
string of text now it's it's obviously
not the words it's some embedding of
those words into a vector and uh you
know that is what this initial module is
doing is turning words into vectors
using for example like word DEC or some
other
embedding so then what the um attention
layer does is is for each for each token
so so for each X embedding here or each
word essentially um it generates a query
Vector which is just uh depends on on
this embedding and a key vector and a
value Vector so these all depend on this
value of x usually we use like a MLP for
example uh to to learn this these
relationships and then it's got this
kind of information communication
between the different uh um vectors in
the sequence so so what we do is we take
this query Vector from this from this uh
from this token and we multiply it by
the key Vector from each of the other
tokens and that's kind of and that
produces a score this is like a a a
product here that produces a score that
says like how close is this key to my
query
vector and and we pass it through a
softmax to make sure that it's between
the score is between zero and one and
what we interpret this score to B is
basically the attention it's saying um
how much should we attend to each of the
other tokens in the sequence when we're
when we're processing this this token
here and when you actually look at the
attention values uh and you can
interpret the network by looking at
these attention values you can see that
for example it here if you if you look
at the Learned attention it will have a
very high attention on for example dog
so it knows the relation that it is
referring to dog and this kind of helps
it process the process the input
stream um so
uh so that's essentially how attention
is working um the the mathematical
function is here like I said we have
these query key and value vectors here
that are just functions of the input and
then we do this uh uh cross
communication with with a softmax so
that this is the
attention there is a lot more to be said
about attention and I've just given you
the one slide overview here so if you're
interested in implementing implementing
it there's a or implementing chat GPT
itself there's a minimal implement
version here which is really really good
to learn about
it and have a look at the paper if you
if you want to know more about attention
in
general okay so we're at the end of the
lecture so uh what I described to you
were that deep networks can be really
hard to train and their performance can
suffer a lot um and the reason is we
have these three big sources of error
when we're training or networks we have
approximation error you know the the
space of possible fun functions that the
network can represent have estimation
error this is from the finit of the
training data and then optimization
error the fact that the optimizer
doesn't always give you the global minim
the loss
function so we talked about lots of
different strategies for uh correcting
these errors and producing a more robust
and performant model um and yeah uh
hopefully these two lectures have given
you like a a recap or a a a worldwind
introduction into deep learning and yeah
um I'll see you next time office it's
giving you the
El okay thank you